a Republican Senate minority leader
Mitch McConnell is scared he's scared to
disavow Donald Trump and to say it's
time for the Republican party to go in a
different direction we know it's what he
thinks Mitch McConnell made it very
clear in that speech he gave on the
floor of the Senate just days after the
January 6 2021 Trump riots we know uh
that Mitch McConnell is not pleased with
Trump he is not pleased with Trump
politically he's not pleased with Trump
ideologically I can't imagine that he
sees Trump positively after Trump has
made numerous racist comments and dog
whistles about Mitch McConnell's own
wife Elaine Chao based on her Asian
Heritage there's no way in hell for all
of the bad things we can say about Mitch
McConnell there's no way in hell Mitch
McConnell is a trump guy but Mitch
McConnell also uh in many cases puts
politics above his individual beliefs
and above principle and so Mitch
McConnell isn't willing to say
I don't want Trump to be the next
nominee and I don't want Trump to be the
next president Mitch McConnell is saying
I will vote for whoever ultimately is
the nominee and in fact yesterday he was
asked by CNN's Manu Raju on the heels of
Nikki Haley announcing that she too is
running for the Republican Presidential
nomination he was asked will you support
Nikki Haley and he sort of said well
it's going to be very competitive and
then he said he will support whoever is
ultimately the nominee
you might have Nikki Haley's decision to
jump in to the race today do you think
that it's time for the party to find you
fresh face and move away from Donald
Trump well what I think we're going to
have is a vigorous primary vigorous with
the number of candidates making their
case
and the American people those who are
registered Republicans who are going to
participate in these primaries are going
to decide who they want to nominate and
I think it's going to be very very
competitive in these primaries and we'll
hope for the best and obviously I'm
going to support whoever the nominee
ultimately is obviously obviously there
is no scenario in which Mitch McConnell
would not support whoever is the
eventual nominee now there are people
who will write to me and say David that
it's really not a big deal that Mitch
McConnell is saying that he's a
republican he's in Republican leadership
of course he's going to support whoever
the candidate ultimately is we know that
no I get that the problem is that it's a
Brazen partisanship where for the good
of the country I would like to see Mitch
McConnell at least be open to the idea
that if the nominee were truly horrible
he would think for himself and even
though I know he would never say it it
would be nice to hear from Mitch
McConnell something along the lines of
listen I am a Republican and I have
faith that Republicans will select the
best candidate to represent us but I am
not but a blind follower and I am not a
moral and while I disagree with Joe
Biden
he is a good man and an honest man who
wants what he believes is best for the
country and if indeed the Republican
Party selected someone that I believe
would be destructive to this country I
would cross party lines he'll he never
can do it it's of course never going to
do it he will always end up justifying
the vote for the Republican but I would
like to see them at least pretend not to
be overtly partisan hacks
it they would be lying in a sense so am
I saying I would like to see them live
well though I would love for that to be
the truth it is not and so Mitch
McConnell is being honest yeah Trump
said racist things about my wife yeah
Trump incited an Insurrection yeah I've
said Trump is a problem in so many
different ways but I'm going to vote for
whoever is the nominee even if that is
Donald Trump and this is similar to the
bill Barr line we when we saw these
recent interviews by uh Bill William
Barr
Trump's former Attorney General
criticized Trump significantly and then
say well I'm not going to vote for a
Democrat obviously not going to vote for
a Democrat they are telling the truth in
that sense and uh at least for once they
aren't lying but Mitch McConnell making
it very clear whoever they put up there
he would vote for over a Democrat we'll
have these clips available for you on
our YouTube channel youtube.com the
davidpackman show we also have the
YouTube channel in Spanish now available
closing in on our first thousand
subscribers on the Spanish YouTube
channel which you can find at YouTube
actually you know what I'm going to set
up a redirect
davidpackman.com Spanish okay just to
make it easier
davidpackman.com Spanish will take you
to the Spanish language YouTube channel